animation is one of the most satisfying
things for a developer because it can
turn a boring cookie cutter feature into
something really special in today's
video we'll build a modal window and
react from scratch but on top of that
we'll also bring in a library called
framer motion to implement a bunch of
crazy animations for the modal in this
beginner-friendly tutorial you'll learn
how to style a modal with css then how
to manage its open and closed state with
javascript and most importantly how to
implement declarative animations with
framer motion and react and i'll even
show you how to drag and move a modal
around the screen and explain the
physics behind motion like this and
we'll look at a bunch of other cool
tricks and best practices along the way
if you're new here like and subscribe
and if you like this tutorial upgrade to
a pro membership on fireship io to get
access to the sequel where we build a
notification system with framer before
we jump into the code let's take a
closer look at what we're building today
and by the way there's also a live demo
where you can play around with this
project before you build it we have a
button that when clicked will add a
backdrop to the entire screen and then
animate a window on top of it then to
close it we can either click the close
button or click outside of it on the
backdrop which will automatically
trigger the outro animation modals are a
very useful ui feature when you need to
focus the user's attention and or you
don't want to navigate them to an
entirely different route you can also do
complex things inside of them for
example the entire login feature for
fireship io is handled inside of a modal
what you don't want to do is pop one of
these things up after a few seconds
asking someone to subscribe to your
newsletter or even worse asking them to
accept cookies let's go ahead and jump
into the code to get started we'll first
need to generate a react project and for
that i'm using create react app once
created i'll go ahead and open it up in
vs code and install our only dependency
which is framer motion framer by the way
is maintained by the team behind the
framer design tool and is a very well
maintained and polished library for
implementing animations it's not the
only way to animate and react but in my
opinion it's the most intuitive approach
for a feature like this now to run the
app run npm start from the command line
and that should bring up the default
react app on localhost 3000. next we'll
go into the app.js file and delete all
the boilerplate code from there i'll go
into the index.css file and delete that
code as well and import normalize css
this is a cool little trick with create
react app that will just give us a blank
slate to work with when it comes to css
then from there i'm going to paste in
all the css for this project which you
can get on github by the way we'll come
back here to explain the important
styles as we move along at this point
you should see an empty black background
and now we're ready to implement our
first animation which is a button that
gets bigger when we hover over it and
gets smaller when we press it first we
can import the motion component from
framer motion then in the jsx add a
regular button that has a class name of
save button and currently when clicked
doesn't do anything now to animate it we
can simply swap out the regular button
for a motion button motion actually
wraps all of the html elements for you
and provides additional props to
configure an animation like while hover
will make the button bigger when you
hover over it and then while tap will
make it smaller to give it the
impression of being pushed in and just
like that we've already created our
first animation but you might be
wondering why would i want to use framer
motion over just regular css animations
well for one it's just easier and
results in more simplified code but on
top of that framework can do a lot of
things that css can't like listen to
different browser events and integrate
with the actual state of your react
application it's just more developer
friendly to work with and that'll become
apparent as we build out our next
feature the modal to build it we have
two moving parts here which we will
organize in the components directory
first we have the backdrop which is just
an overlay that sits across the entire
screen and makes everything else look
dark then the modal window sits on top
of it and that's where the user's
attention will be focused when working
on a larger react project it's generally
a good practice to write one component
per file in this demo i have a directory
for each main component with an
index.jsx file inside of it a little
trick in vs code is to hit the button
for a new file and then write out the
entire file path with a slash and it
will automatically create the directory
for you let's start by building the
backdrop we'll first import the motion
component then define our own custom
component called backdrop and export it
as the default from this file the
component itself will take two props the
first one is children which allows us to
embed additional components in between
the tags for the backdrop and the second
one is on click which allows us to pass
a custom event handler into the
component to update the global state
when the backdrop is clicked that allows
us to think of this as a dump component
that doesn't have its own internal state
to manage in the jsx we set up a motion
div and define the on click handler as
the function that gets passed in as a
prop and then the children will go in
between the motion div tags it has a
class name of backdrop and let's go
ahead and take a look at the css before
we start animating remember it's an
overlay so we give it a position of
absolute and set it in the top left
corner with a height and width of 100
then we'll give it a black background
but we still want to see the elements
that are underneath it and an easy way
to do that is to simply use a hex color
but then add an additional two
characters for the opacity and finally
we want to center the children both
horizontally and vertically which we can
do with display flex now with our style
set we can go back to our component and
define the various animation states to
make the backdrop fade in and fade out
the initial state should be invisible
which we can set with an opacity of zero
then when it's active we want to animate
it to an opacity of one and then when
the animation is finished we want to go
back to an opacity of zero which we can
set with the exit property and that's
all there is to it but it's not very
useful without some content inside of it
let's now go ahead and implement the
modal component at the top we'll import
motion again as well as the backdrop
component that we just built then we'll
define and export a component called
modal that has two props one is a
function to close the modal and the
other is the text that we want to
display inside of the window in the jsx
we declare the backdrop component
because that will always sit behind the
window itself and when the backdrop is
clicked it will automatically close the
window now because we're using the
children prop in the backdrop we can add
elements inside of it like the motion
div here which will represent the window
now the first thing i want to do here is
set up the click handler and call event
stop propagation normally when you click
on something it bubbles up the dom to
find the first event handler to take
care of it that default browser behavior
would cause the modal to automatically
close anytime the content inside of it
was clicked which is not something we
would want in this case the next thing
we'll do is add a modal class to it and
let's quickly take a look at the css to
make the width and height responsive i'm
using the clamp and min functions from
css clamp in this case will attempt to
set the width to 700 pixels but if the
screen is too small then it will go up
to 90 if needed or if the screen is too
big it will go to a maximum of 50
percent of the screen width this is a
really cool trick to know in css because
otherwise to make the modal responsive
we'd have to set up media queries and
things like that which would take a lot
more code okay now back to our component
we have a property called variance that
references an object called drop in this
object allows you to define multiple
custom animation states that's really
cool because you can use it to create a
complex sequence of animations based on
different ways the user might interact
with your app in this animation we have
three states hidden visible and exit
when the window is hidden we'll
translate it along the y-axis by
negative 100 of the view height when it
exits it will drop beneath the viewport
to positive 100 of the view height when
it is visible though we'll put it on its
natural position of zero on the y axis
the end result is an animation that
drops in from the top and lands in the
middle then when it leaves it drops even
further to the bottom now one additional
cool thing we can do here is tweak the
transition settings when it becomes
visible i'm going to set the duration to
point one second and give it a spring
type animation to make it look kind of
bouncy and that provides a very easy way
to make your animations look special i
don't want to get into the physics of it
but damping is a decrease in the
amplitude of an oscillation as a result
of energy being drained from the system
to overcome frictional or other
resistive forces if you turn it down
really low the spring will never stop
bouncing but if you turn it up too high
then the spring won't have much of a
balance at all with stiffness if you
turn it down really low then it'll make
the spring react very slowly and vice
versa if you turn it up very high if you
want to dive deeper into spring
animations i'll link to a brilliant blog
post that actually visualizes the
relationship between damping and
stiffness in a framer motion component
the final thing we'll want to do in this
component is go back down to the motion
div and add props for the different
states like initial animate and exit and
now the final question becomes how do we
actually trigger this animation in the
react app for that we'll head back into
our root app component and inside of it
import the use state hook from react as
well as the modal we just built in order
to open and close it we need some state
on this component that will tell us
whether or not it's currently opened or
closed and we can easily set that up
with the use state hook it'll have a
default value of false and then just to
make our code a little more readable
here i'm going to set up functions for
close and open that will toggle the
value between true and false now with
our state setup we can go down to the
launch model button that we created at
the beginning and define its on click
event handler to run the close function
if the modal is open otherwise run the
open function that allows us to toggle
the state from the button but we also
need to toggle the state from the modal
itself like when the user clicks on the
backdrop or from the close button within
the window itself so if modal open is
true then we'll render the modal
component and it will take the props of
modal open as well as handle close to
make it aware of the data or state in
the parent app component if we check it
out in the browser we should now have a
working modal window but there's one
problem here notice how that it animates
in perfectly but when we click the close
button it just disappears instead of
animating out the reason this happens is
because the modal is completely removed
from the dom when the state changes
luckily though framer motion has a
mechanism to rescue us from this
predicament we can import the animate
presence component and put our modal
inside of it to keep it visible
temporarily even after it's been removed
from the dom there are two important
props here first one is initial which
will be set to false to disable any
initial animations and the second one is
exit before enter setting it to true
will ensure that all nodes have finished
animating before they're actually
removed and we can also do more advanced
things here like listen to life cycle
events if we go ahead and try it again
we now get the full sequence of
animations from enter to exit
congratulations you just built an
animated modal window with react and
framer motion oh and i almost forgot i
told you i would make the modal window
draggable to accomplish that all we have
to do is add the drag prop to the motion
dim and now you're free to drag it
around the screen i'm going to go ahead
and wrap things up there but if you want
to learn some more advanced concepts
like how to build a notification feed
and work with drag and drop gestures in
framer consider upgrading to fireship
pro to get access to the sequel thanks
for watching and i will see you in the
next one